hello everybody and welcome to another
video today I would like to show you
with you hi to create surface game game
of life with my Muller genius as you can
see it's random restarts and it also has
some buttons like start strobe and clear
and the generations this game is from
free code card
there are several user cases or user
stories hmm uh you'll see how complete
each one of these there is also we could
be telling that gives you all the
instructions and stay rules there are
several rules and actually to create one
or two days to read and understand
everything so then I will be able to
code it I'm not gonna get into a lot of
details about the the rules right now
but you will simulator that we will
discuss some of them now I'm only using
angularjs and it's not food service as
they usually do and so will create this
project in coachmen I will leave in the
description box the codes for the code
fan and also I will share it on github
too so if you can't see it very clear
what am i typing or you know if you want
to reread it you can also search it in
my code pan or in github I will create
writing the HTML and have already
written there Dave ng up game of life
and ng-controller game of life
controller then I'm going to start
writing a table and inside there I'm
going to have an NG repeat row in rows
and after that an ng-click
in the ng click will be activate which
will be a class and it will have the
parameter rows don't index off
roll and index continue with an NG
repeat call in rugged course the goal is
for column and last but not least
include an NG class I will name and I
will name drive my variable for call
don't octave equals one and cool and old
column dirt octave greater than one and
that is my table you won't be able to
see trick now we will first have to
write some CSS code and then some
JavaScript code to give it some
functionality all right think now we are
good to eat the table
yes so let's get going with the patterns
first I'm going to write a class
components that you will styled up later
in the CSS and then for the three
patterns I'm going to create an ng-click
and inside there I'm gonna a function
the first one will be stop with the
names - another one will be start with
the parameter Falls and the third button
will be clear with the name clear and
it's another one thing that you're going
to need is their generation and just
give it a parametric generations all
right we are done with the HTML and
let's go to CSS we are going we're not
going to write a lot of things just the
basics and of course then you can stir
it however you like it we're going to
have a table
and dhdt
with border one pixel solid black and
border collapse
I will be columns then the table I'm
going to give it a margin order and in
this way it will be in the center of our
screen you can add a background color in
my case will be white smoke but you can
adjust it to your preferences
I'm also going to continue with it TT
and I'm going to give width and height
all right just give the class new a
background color of orange and then the
old the background color of foreign
straights I think my last class will be
components and it's about the buttons
and the generation I'm just going to
give the basic stylings and now we are
ready to focus on the JavaScript so
JavaScript here is going to be a little
bit longer than it usually is at least
in the other record pan sorry free could
come challenges because here there are
many many rules I'm going to read some
of the tools from Wikipedia the game of
life is made by the by Conway's is a
mathematician
so let me give you a short description
of what is that we are building right
now so far I created the creeps with
rows and columns and now I would select
to make sure that any alive so with pure
than to live neighbors dies as if it
caused by an to population to any live
cell with two or three live neighbours
lives of the next generation tree anyone
so with more than three live neighbours
dies as if by overpopulation and for any
debts well with exactly three live
neighbours becomes a live cell as if
their reproduction the initial pattern
constitutes the stage of the system the
first generation is created by applying
the above rules unit annually to every
cell in the six births and deaths with
your cement Annesley and the discrete
moments at which this happens is
sometimes called ethic the rules
continue to be applied repeatedly to
create further generations if you search
over the internet now you will see that
there are a couple of algorithms that
can describe what we are trying to do
here in south street and it will be very
helpful to take a look at some of this
algorithms as I mentioned in the
beginning of this video it took me a lot
of hours to understand every rule and
then figure out how exactly I was going
to write them
all right some basic things about
angular to the ng app that you used in
the HTML is a directive the tells
angular Julia's that this is the root
element of the application and all
angular applications must have courage
element then the controller directive
defines the controller of course
so let's focus now clearly on the
JavaScript part we're generating the
seeds which means it that we are going
to create a function with the name
random seed inside there I'm going to
have a for loop for I equals 0 I smaller
than road marks called marks divided by
2 and I plus plus inside there I'm going
to have another variable with a name row
is now I'm going to have the math tilt
floor math dot random and row max minus
1 we're going to do the same for columns
okay I started writing the function
counts live live neighbors once again
the name will then check neighbors the
function will have two parameters fro
and cold
I'm going to have a variable count equal
zero then a for loop with VAR i equals
fro minus 1 and I plus 1 I plus plus
another for loop with the J for columns
and inside there I'm going to have an if
statement if I is different than bro or
J is different than column and and scope
George rows PI plus sorry and scope
don't rows I don't cause J then I'm
going to need another gift statement let
me write everything here correctly and
so I'm going to continue with an if
statement all right and I can see also
the great sister so if scope to chose I
don't cause Jay don't octave is greater
or equal that one then count plus plus
and in the end you wanna to return your
count variable alright I'm just checking
to make sure everything is works fine
and I think that's it's great so now I'm
going to continue with some other
functions all right
scope dude stop game equals function and
then inside there the only thing I want
is the interval touch console interval
all right that looks good I don't need
anything else and let's continue with
activate scope dude activate equals
function and in the parenthesis right
bro and call sculpted rows row DOTA
calls cool dude
octave equals 1 and we are ready with
this function also know learn interval
let's go dude start game equals function
random so now your start writing
original function which is really
important
maybe it's the most important a function
of this game scope to generation equals
0 it's random random seeds and try them
seeds is another function so interval
equals dollar interval function and open
brackets inside these brackets we're
going to have scope dot generation plus
plus and then we need two for loops the
first one will be for the rows and the
next one of course for conan's adjust
your parameters
I'm alright and inside there we're going
to have a variable another variable I'm
sorry for these so over know off
neighbors equals check neighbors hi Jade
then scope judge rose by daughter calls
Jay don't neighbors equals know about
flavors alright we will continue one
more time with do more for loops the
parameters here are the same as the ball
so you can just copy and paste them and
of course we will have some if
statements in the first if statement you
will meet $1 scope don't Rose hi don't
calls J dot octave greater fun and
inside there open your brackets again
and try to keep scope to chose I don't
calls J George neighbors is greater or
equal to 4 or scope Toros I don't cause
Jay don't neighbors is smaller than one
then open brackets ends right once again
scope no choice I don't cause J dot
octave equal 0
now you need an else statement scope
don't Rose I don't cause J dot octave
plus plus and another else statements
which will include an eighth statement
and it will and it will be scope dojos i
calls j neighbors equals equals three
and scoped or chose i dot cos J dot
octave equals one alright now I'm going
to finish this function and then
find the mistake it's it's a thing I
know where it is but like just be sure I
it must be a bracket that I forego too
close let me check it whoo yes here it
is the old statement should have also
brought it today that I forgot to eat
great now let's continue with the start
game in the HTML code we write the start
with the parameter false that's not
going to do it scope don't start it was
true and then I'm going to tell the
clear function so we will meet once
again two for loops with our usual
parameters of golden spends of rows and
columns and inside there just try to
scope those rows PI dot cos Jay don't
octave equals zero all right and that's
it guys I hope that you like this game
and I know that the rules are quite
complicated that's why I mentioned that
you should go to pedia or to any other
website and search for the algorithms
some gold or some examples try to play
this game and this will help you to
better understand it so now we can see
the generation we can use the boards we
can click on eight then we have the
three buttons that clear one that it
clears everything and of course you can
refresh the website and see one more
time how this game is thank you very
much for watching have a great day
and if you liked this video please sir
and subscribe thank you very much
[Music]